[Musique]
tu sais que tu peux dire quand tu es le
plus grand espion du monde long lance sterling
tout le monde connaît le nom
travail attrapez
un Chris - c'est trop c'est probablement la
bonne quantité retournez toujours travailler à la
maison ça va changer l'espionnage pour toujours
ça s'appelle la dissimulation biodynamique
imaginez si je peux vous faire attendre
un rouleau s'il vous plaît
disparaître disparaître pourquoi le
dites-vous  comme ça pour un aliment que
la technologie de dissimulation de nouvelle génération vous
ne l'auriez pas sous la main, est-ce
que
je l'aurais en main, montrez-le-
moi bien sûr euh que puis-je vous offrir un
verre j'ai de l'eau potable
substitut de repas mmm  nous avons pris un verre des
trucs de régime a un arrière-goût bizarre
quelle est la technologie euh eh bien
ça a marché le sujet semble désorienté
Walter qu'as-tu fait
hé Lance regarde-moi regarde-toi je ne peux pas
ne pas te regarder Walter je peux voir mes fesses
et  ton visage en même temps  moi les pigeons
sont partout personne ne les remarque fille
c'est l'ancien espion le plus parfait
pourrait mieux te décharger maintenant
c'est tout je vais jouer avec toi
je suis Bert j'élève la voix je
ne devrais probablement pas élever la voix à  toi j'ai
besoin que tu me brûles Walter tu l'
oiseau toi-même
toi